In a tweet thread exchanged with JetBlue on
April 17th, writer Mackenzie Fegan had a few
questions about the airline’s new boarding
procedure.
No boarding pass.
No ID.
Instead, a camera and screen verified her
identity against a US Customs and Border Patrol
database, then let her on the plane.
Some passengers might consider the increasing
use of facial recognition in everyday life
convenient, some might think it’s Orwellian,
but it’s already everywhere.
The question is, how far will it go?
Turns out, even some of those developing the
technology are scared of what the answer might
be.
This is your Bloomberg QuickTake on Facial
Recognition.
In May, San Francisco became the first American
city to block police and other agencies from
using facial recognition software.
The biggest concerns are really
around civil liberties and whether you're
essentially enabling a kind of totalitarian
state with this technology, which sort of
seems to be the way things are heading.
There are concerns about the use of this technology
by law enforcement and by police.
How’d we get here?
Like other artificial intelligence applications,
facial recognition initially developed slowly,
beginning in the 1960s.
Then around 2012, with the help of newly available
high-def cameras, machine learning, and giant
databases of photos to increase accuracy,
it advanced in a hurry.
facial recognition takes images
from video cameras and tries to identify the
faces of people in those images.
it does so by taking some key points
in the face usually and doing measurements
of the distance between all those various
points.
In December 2018, London police made their
first arrest based on facial recognition,
after cross-checking photos of pedestrians
in tourist hotspots against a database of
known criminals.
In New Delhi, a police trial reportedly identified
3,000 missing children in just four days.
So if it involves catching criminals and finding
missing children, why would anyone be against
it?
For that, one might look at the most developed
facial recognition network in the world, in
China.
CCTV and facial recognition have
been used in combination to create this sort
of vast surveillance apparatus and that's
been particularly applied against certain
ethnic minority groups, but even in western
democracies people are concerned about police
departments using this technology to try to
find suspects, or even people who might be
involved in legitimate protests, so they could
be tracked.
And those are just concerns about the technology
when it works as intended.
A study from the MIT Media Lab found that
white men in a sample were correctly identified
99 percent of the time, while error rates
of up to 35% were found when it came to darker
skinned women.
Microsoft came out last year.
It was the first major tech company to say,
they really feel uncomfortable with deploying
this technology until there's clear regulation
around it.
They were then joined by Amazon, which seconded
those calls.
It seems like some other companies are kind
of plowing ahead without such qualms at all.
To stake out some guidelines, the Algorithmic
Justice Center and Georgetown University Law
Center unveiled the Safe Face Pledge, which
asks companies not to provide facial AI for
autonomous weapons or sell to law enforcement
unless explicit laws are debated and passed
to allow it.
A few companies have signed on, but notably
not Microsoft or Amazon, possibly loathe to
lose the opportunity to sell facial recognition
to police departments and governments the
world over.
So what's preventing your image from saying
a whole lot more about you than it used to?
Face it, not much.